i've had two kidney transplants
the last one was in december 2019 very
luckily just before lockdown where
my dad kindly donated me a kidney
hal cohen takes immunosuppressing drugs
to stop his body rejecting his new
kidney
but they also mean he hasn't generated a
response to the covered vaccine and has
no antibodies
i likely don't have any protection from
coronavirus
with cases rising and legal restrictions
dropped july the 19th
could mean the loss of freedom for the
vulnerable
so even things that i would take for
granted previously like
having a haircut i don't know now if
there's places where i can go
where for example the person cutting to
her will be
wearing a mask but there'll be too many
other people there who who aren't
wearing a mask
even basic things in that now see
a bit of a challenge going forward hal
is not alone
there are 3.8 million clinically
extremely vulnerable people in the uk
500 000 of them are immunocompromised
meaning they may not be protected by the
vaccine
they are people who have autoimmune
diseases who've had organ transplants or
some types of cancer
a group of leading charities says there
needs to be more support from the
government
with furlough coming to an end many fear
having to go back to work
there has absolutely been a title wave
of people getting
in touch with us both our partner
charities on this
and us as well we have a couple of
counsellors we are overwhelmed
with people asking for support and
feeling distressed
some scientists say the immunosuppress
should continue to shield
we need to let people know that they may
not
be protected against the virus even if
they've had
one or two doses of the vaccine
we need to let people know that they
therefore are at ongoing risk
if the case numbers continue to increase
in the way that they are
and that isn't magically going to go
away on monday
when a number of restrictions will be
lifted
we are all going to have to learn to
live with the virus
but doing so is about to get much harder
for many clinically vulnerable people
jeremiah milwaukee sky news